Speaker 1: Let's go to court here from
south Florida. Welcome to the show.
Speaker 2: David.
Speaker 1: Hi, Amy. I can hear.
Speaker 2: You. How's it going? It's going well.
Speaker 1: Thank you.
Speaker 2: Longtime fan. Since 2020, actually,
I've been a fan. I appreciate it. I got a
question. Really? Like my my family's a
little bit trumpet. I have some issues
talking to them about bias. Commentary. So one
of the things that I'm just curious to know.
But the whole thing with Pop and Pelosi. Happening
now. The poppy going into his house and breaking
in. If it would have been the other way around,
it would have been Trump in his house and someone
breaks into his house. Yeah. And attacks on Trump.
I'm wondering how the right media would have been
attacked and commentated on that segment.
Speaker 1: Will you know the answer to
that? I know you know the answer.
Speaker 2: I do. I just want.
Speaker 1: To say that this is the culture
that is encouraged by Democrats who want
to defund the police and let crime
run rampant and open the borders
and Britain and blah, blah, blah. But yeah,
that's it's of course, what they would have done.
Speaker 2: Yeah. Yeah, yeah, exactly. Exactly.
Speaker 1: And they would have been a lot of
people with it, by the way. I mean, listen,
they've convinced a lot of people that this
entire thing was like a false flag inside job
with a gay lover, even though there's no evidence
of that. And if it were someone breaking into
Trump's house and, you know, hitting Melania with
a hammer, they'd be calling for congressional
hearings. It would be 24 seven on Fox News.
I can't even imagine what they would be doing.
Speaker 2: That's my thought, too. I don't want to
put it out there because I'm like, you know, like
I want to show people and my friends and family,
like, do you see the bias out there? Like,
can you really understand that? Yeah. If it
was the other way around, it would just be
constant 24 hour, like, look what's going
on. The 100 and a.
Speaker 1: 100.
Speaker 2: Also. And I guess that's where
I'm frustrated and I get those pain points
like I do you not see reality, but it's.
Speaker 1: So you said your family is kind
of Trumpy. What kind of stuff are they saying?
Speaker 2: Exactly that, exactly that that,
you know, like they literally ate it up. You
know, Elon Musk published it and they said, hey,
look, it's you know, it's it's already closed
out. It's you know, it was his lover. And I
said, but we that doesn't make any sense.
Speaker 1: Like that is your family.
Speaker 2: Cuban Um, yes, they are. CUBAN So
you hit in the know with that. But actually
I was talking to my in-laws who are kind of a
mix. They're from other parts of from, you know,
South America specifically.
Speaker 1: Not Argentina, I hope.
Speaker 2: Yes, I ha. Oh, no. Oh, my God.
Speaker 1: Oh, that's horrifying.
Speaker 2: That's I don't want
to say I don't want to fake it. I
know you're Argentinian, dear God. And I said.
Speaker 1: Well, listen, you're bumming me out,
but it sounds like you're fighting the good
fight and doing what you can to push back.
Speaker 2: I'm trying. Yeah.
Speaker 1: Thank you. All right.
Thank you for the call very much. Appreciate
that. There is more here from south Florida